you
hi everyone is cherry I'm on leach s org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game so let's see what to do against e4
how about we try Oh
d6 that's different
all right and let's try five right away
so this is an invite to a queenless
middle game let's see if we have that
now
okay so I'm just going to take and let's
see how white recaptures ah with the
Queen so at some point I could gain a
valuable tempo against the queen with
knight c6 however I'm not sure I want to
go in for that right away now let's hold
off let's go it's Knight f6
I'd like to see this bishop move
somewhere other than b5 right away I'm
expecting knight c6 Bishop b5 would be
played so I mean if it goes to c4 then
maybe I'm more inclined to play knight
c6 should the pin occur then then well
some time was wasted by white
okay so let's still hold off I'm not
going to go with the kingside fiend keto
so Bishop e7 it is
so let's see what I'm the best is doing
alright I'm assuming there is some
queenside castle idea being prepped
okay well it's Castle queenside castle
or not now I could play this soon and
there won't be a pin do I want to do
that I also have to be pretty careful
this rook is opposite my queen so first
things first this is a pretty half-open
position I think knight c6 has its place
now I was played pretty quick Queen to
d2 hmm okay well one of my thoughts is
that if I play h6 there might be some
sacrifice there
a bit concerning I could also consider
just some development Bishop to e6
let's consider something though we are
castled on opposite wings and so should
I be looking forward to expanding on the
queenside with a 6 b5 rattling the night
position and maybe not such an important
thing - well forget about important
maybe it's just a bad idea all together
not only might there be a sacrifice but
I'm giving my opponents something to
bite out the jeep on advance I don't
want files to open towards my king
so forget about h6 and maybe forget
about Bishop here
hmm let's consider a six or bishop here
if I play a six first Bishop here is
going to run into some tempo moves with
b5 I could maybe even still play Bishop
here if the bishop is on c4 I think
what's most important is that I look to
crack at their King position somehow at
the same time I have to be mindful of be
five you know this rook is still
opposite my queen
you know if the Queen is no longer in
front of the rook this can be a bit of
an issue so let's see I D I could go
with also is Bishop to e6 instead of
this kind of idea maybe get one more
developing move in and then I'm even in
a spot to offer some exchanges I am down
space-wise a little bit of a space
disadvantage here efore versus d6 I
wouldn't be you know I shouldn't be so
shy to exchange some pieces Bishop to e6
with then Knight to d7 is a way to offer
dark square Bishop exchange if I'm going
to move this Knight I need some coverage
on d5 so Bishop e6 would provide that
type of coverage yeah I'm leaning
towards Bishop to e6 you
let's go with Bishop to e6 it's
developing after all and let's see will
there be some type of caveman idea
h4 who knows maybe even g4 is a gambit
to open up the G file anything's
possible here material and that's so
much well not not nearly as important is
having open files towards the enemy King
so you can see this type of at least on
the surface it may appear to be a bit
outlandish g4 where there's a couple
different pieces that can take but that
allows some direct pressure against the
heart of my king side structure g7 so
I'm happy to see that they're thinking
so let's see what they come up with will
be a light square Bishop move Knight to
d5 this I have covered a queen move
preparing this I could scoop my Queen
over to c8 just to get out of this this
is another benefit we might say applying
Bishop to e6 I have this square open for
my Queen Knights
we all have all good nights all four
nights are in that sweet spot the
chessboard those key 16 squares where
they have a maximum number of moves
what to do
if white does nothing I think this is my
idea to kind of just get rolling here
some on the queenside
what more king to be one it's usually a
pretty common move to see after
queenside castle I don't know if it's
really so important to do right now just
to cover a - this this might have this
might be capturing White's attention
some because I do have pressure here
after all I'm only realizing that now
but yeah queenside castle king b1 pretty
typical hmm what more sometimes you'll
see rook to e8 although because I
decided to post up on e6 with my bishop
I don't see that this is such a good
idea at least right now there's too much
traffic on the e-file for this rook to
really have some influence not not
enough direct pressure on e4 with this
rook e8 move it is a half-open file at
some point it may it may hit maybe
relevant but I'm not seeing it as such
right now
they're stunned trying to come up with
the plan may not be a bad idea to have
my night on c5 offering the exchange a
night on c5 drifting towards the the
queenside here some pressure against the
pawn this mace this may still be an idea
to e8 yeah I want it I want to shy away
from h6 done with that be it be
different well it'd be different if they
were Castle kingside
h6 is certainly something but um you
know this isn't so much of a bother to
me it's not like my bishop is outside
here and my knight on f6 can't move the
bishop is breaking any type of pin
against my knight
so after blitzing out the first eight
moves the move nine is where I'm the
best ten is in the think tank
sometimes there could be some tactical
opportunities for black with you know if
h6 and then the bishop goes to h4 there
are I some ideas with Knight takes e4
and if Bishop takes Bishop there could
be Knight takes Knight first with check
this may be a reason in some situations
to let's say not have the King on b1 but
again I don't know if this h6 move is
something I would really like to do in
an opposite sides castling type position
hmmm I wonder if they have it no they're
still here their connection appears to
be fine this is quite a thing it's
certainly a position where you have to
come up with some type of plan so let's
see what that plan is maybe they do have
a connection thing in these very words
I'm sharing right now we'll go unheard
you just uh I won't be uploading this
we'll see am i just talking to myself
right now it may be the case that these
very words are ones that I only hear oh
I'm running out of things to say this is
what happens oh there we go
I was ready to say this is what happens
when too much time is spent by my
opponent novel not too much time but
anyhow they're here they're live they
made a move they developed and my first
impression is that it's a bit on the
slow side it's so kind of chock it up is
on a bit of a half developing move it is
off the back rank it is maybe preparing
to play rook here and blast open the
center okay
so I guess these words will be heard
after all my opponent is here well I am
leaning towards a 6 B 5 and the threat
of B 4 is is something is he is the only
defender a V 4
I'm going to go with it 86 it is
rook a to e1 or will there be another
think here let's see we both have really
good structures this is a position where
I look into piece placement quite a bit
also the number one thing really is King
safety Castle down opposite wings I
would really like to see the B or a file
open up alright I guess they're
preparing g4 it's the only other move
however no maybe I'm off with that there
may be another idea behind h3 and that
is to secure a queen position on e3 yeah
it could be that g4 is lined up but I
think right around this moment they're
sensing efore will need some support
so in other words if I play b5 I'm
expecting Queen III so that if I give
the knight of boot the knight can move
hmm I think I should still go with b5
and hang on for a moment I wonder if I
should hold off on that right around
this point I'm actually considering rook
to e8 is on b5 Queen III I have to be on
the lookout for a 5 I could kind of
force the action I could play b4 but I
think white would be perfectly fine with
applying Knight to d5 I have enough
support for it and if I'm taking with
the knight then I end up in a fork if I
take with the bishop pawn takes where is
he going to go I think right around this
point I want to have my rook on ei
I will make the white queen not feel
it's safe on e3 so rookie a queen III
maybe then Knight d7 really uh combating
this 'if I've advanced and also breaking
some making it a little bit more
indirect huh you know the white rook
doesn't have as direct sight with my
queen anymore with my knight on D 7 so
maybe rook e8 is a is an idea
hmm I wonder up to eh now this night
cannot yet just jump right in there
let's play Rocky eight
you
I have Knight to d7 offering some
exchanges maybe soon I have this b5 move
hitting we'll see o g4 it is alright I
think I want to get on with b5 let's
let's start some action here on the
Queen side did something quite similar
here we both have our rook pawns up a
step
our Knight pawns up a couple steps
okay this is a hole so I don't really
see a way to take advantage of that this
might also be a way to post up on f5 hmm
with this kind of fancy stuff I wonder
about b4 is something you know I was
mentioning earlier white has some space
advantage efore versus d6 in the center
at the same time it's the e4 pond that
is a bit more vulnerable right I have
some pressure on it this is something
this will force a force the issue
white has to react to this type of
pressure against e4 let's see 11 moves
in
White House support for peace on this
square and the most invasive piece
around would be a night kind of view
this F v square an F for squares against
King positions on the Kings side these
spots here for Knights are fantastic a
couple different checking squares for
the night super invasive piece one that
strikes right at the heart of the King
structures or the king positions again
the White King was over here Strong's
posts for the Knights for me maybe a
knight on c4 would be quite good not
sure in this position which is generally
speaking of Knights on uh just looking
at corresponding squares these would be
the key squares for the Knights
depending on where the King positions
are
under six
my threat here is b4 and then Knight
takes e4 a winning upon and really you
know getting there with some uh how to
set some authority really hitting
everything so they've given up the dark
square bishop well not taking with the
pawn no way
got the bishop pair in a strong Bishop I
don't have this is a positional feature
right now but they don't have the
greatest of harmony between their their
Bishop and remaining structure so this
dark square referenced earlier f4 being
a whole this may factor in somehow
okay they could take
ah do I want to do that if I take he's
going to have to find a new home I think
white would like to have a knight
exchange you know Bishop takes pawn
takes Knight here Knight takes Bishop
takes f4
you know there's now three pawns
creeping towards my King I have to come
up with something here
can I just work around this guy must I
work around him
huh to do here hmm
lacking a plan
I'm not sure what to do here Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes I don't really
have a good square these are done it's
the only square here maybe I have to
take with the pawn oh well that might
not be a bad idea actually
oh yeah that is an idea it's uh yeah I I
initially I didn't want to do something
like that because it blocks my bishop
site along this diagonal but maybe
that's only temporary Bishop takes pawn
takes Knight here and if Knight takes
Knight I take with the pawn if Bishop
here I play you for you know I wouldn't
want this bishop to have direct sight
here but let's consider Bishop takes
pawn takes Knight here Knight takes pawn
takes I'm also then threatening Bishop
here winning the Queen so I would be
expecting h4 but maybe right around that
point it's simplified enough where I
could actually I can actually go pawn
grabbing and maybe I will
in fact just take that pawn opposite
color Bishop type position still both of
us with all major pieces I think I will
take that pawn if that happens I think
I'm going to go with this Bishop takes
pawn however let me consider one more
thing and that is the Queen can take on
Bishop takes pawn huh
well I could still jump in here yeah
I'll have some options Knight to be four
maybe but I think I want to get rid of
this guy he's strong he's probably worth
his position oh well he probably is just
as good as a bishop on d5 he is in my in
my house let's say
okay 95 it is moving forward
there's no in-betweener
g5 is not working I get to take an
amount the queen yeah I need to be
taking with the pond and then actually
this this square in fact plays a role in
this game
it's a weakened F for square
rook on e 8 is certainly a useful piece
Knight takes pawn takes it's important
that I have the movie 4 and reply to
Bishop d3 now otherwise there's can be
some a nice blockade here now that if
I'm not mistaken is losing no knight
takes Bishop takes Bishop here there's
an in-between move with rook takes rook
boy that is close to working though
isn't it
what I could do though is focus my
sights on the f4 square still Knight
takes Bishop takes Bishop e5 within
Queen f6 or maybe first a rook exchange
and then Bishop to e5 I think my bishop
is playing in there there Bishop is not
playing in this ending opposite color
bishops think I want to take the knight
to 22
hmm feels like g5 would be played at
some point should I be capturing the
night and then playing h6 now then the
bishop moves and then the f4 is getting
in I want to control f4 if I could
control f4 I think I can control the
game Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
Bishop e5 g5 I takes Knight Bishop takes
rook takes I don't know if that's really
helping me hmm something other than
Knight takes Knight here start with h5
and I don't want this to happen let's
start with the knight takes
now Bishop here there's rook takes rook
first unfortunately I couldn't sit on
camping out here Oh what am I talking
about
I could play rook takes rook and then do
this first the Queen has to recapture on
this otherwise this is winning Queen has
to take oh okay but now I don't know
that I even wanted play bishop here I
think I just play here
superglue my bishop on e5 and follow up
with Queen f6 and there's a very strong
control over the whole position now also
I had a tactic that I could have gone
for hmm yeah I could have captured the
pawn straight away and then followed up
with this but even so I think playing a
balanced you know not investing my
Bishop for this pawn it's still still a
good position for me here but yeah I
should have been I should have
considered something far more direct
here I could have captured on b2 and
then followed up with a fork but maybe
even preferring this because my bishop
is not allowing this type of entry into
my position this is a potential target
maybe well maybe now I just win a pawn
straight away and keep the dark square
Bishop zone yeah this is a problem now
I'm striking at b2 and the bishop I know
the type of flight square I want g6 dark
square what is vulnerable within my own
position
this guy but maybe he's not even a
factor maybe I just don't even care
about him if he's captured so what how
is this a really helpful to these guys I
mean it says I have really good control
over this position now and this pawn
doesn't factor in so much and as it
stands right now I'm ready to rip the
heart out of the structure here as soon
as he's gone dark square weaknesses
everywhere normally this would be the
structure why would like to have but
even that can be broken down with B for
this is a big problem this is the most
serious issue here maybe this is a try
with Bishop takes pawn and then trying
to kick my queen away from defense of
the bishop I think they have to try for
a queen exchange here rook there
just grab that pawn back rank issues
Bishop takes b2 I guess so
on c3 I have on the move C 3 I have
bishop a3 oh my goodness
I really just missed that simple idea oh
my goodness I can't believe I just
missed that what a serious brain cramp
I'm losing my bishop oh brother that is
so bad
and so basic no good
oh man I feel like resigning oh my
goodness that was so basic
ah man Bishop takes pawn I was only
looking at this I was just pointing out
this move earlier if the Queen made a
move I'll play it out a little bit more
it sure would be nice to have a the dark
square Bishop still around Oh awful
awful awful awful Rick to e3 Queen here
not cool at all oh it's tough to play on
after a mistake like that I must say
really really tough now this is an
important pond yeah oh well what to do I
still need a flight square maybe they
give me the piece back and blunder very
unlikely right there push push maybe I
could sneak in here awful awful awful I
guess here
I still need a flight square they go
after something like this maybe then
there's that tactic maybe I could try to
put some pressure clockwise on them
let's get that flight square in there
they are under minute
these guys do control some light squares
from the bishop
let's see need to keep the Queens on
three seconds is not a lot is it ever
the bishop moves I could grab that f2
pond
it's a very good spot for the Queen just
patrolling the dark squares
four seconds think I want to play a h5
maybe pick him off at some point
don't know a good spot for my king guess
king h7 it could be Bishop takes pawn
here at some point maybe even right away
there under 10 seconds
Bishop Vaughn d3 I guess
let's come back over here
a little little floundering action I
need some defense over here
this is unprotected think I need to go
with the clean trade
fortunately
oh my goodness they just dropped on time
oh man what to say mm well I liked how I
played it until I grabbed the pawn and
played g6 and then I'm losing more to
say I mean that was so I can't explain
it
lucky lucky lucky clearly losing this
ending there is no fear of their own
king physician now yeah I don't know I
shouldn't have captured that pawn
okay yeah there we see the blunder rook
d3 grabbing the pawn is losing one more
to go over let's see you know we have a
huh one of them okay II for D 6 and D
form now Philidor exchange variation
don't be like that player okay yeah it's
true I was lucky but yeah
alright so opposite sides castling I
think I got to share a lot I mean right
around this point I was even saying that
many of these words might even be gone
go unheard my opponent was in the think
tank but yeah my delay with Knight to c6
sometimes let me just point out and I
didn't get to share this during the game
sometimes there is an option for Knight
a 6 into c5 although this is something
that Springs about a bit more I believe
when we have same sides castling type
positions I'm pointing this out because
an idea can be to converge on the e4
square you know so there's a reason to
maintain some flexibility with the Queen
Knight okay so go with this yeah it's
pretty even I mean the the the graph is
saying quite a bit it's just a pretty
even position until I guess a slight
drop with Bishop e2 yeah the move that I
thought was a bit of the passing type
half developing type it's just even we
get some pawns rolling and then there's
that drop off with well at what point is
there a drop off Bishop takes f6 you
know b5 Bishop takes f6 so maybe
something other than giving up the
bishop for night because from there I'm
slightly better and then I blunder well
it's it's one that's man I mean if I'm
not blundering that Bishop
white has their work cut out form you
know this position right here exchanging
rooks first again going in for this
right away is losing because my queen is
kicked from the bishops defense so I see
that kind of tactic right that's
something like just g5 after I take care
not that that one sophisticated that I
just highlighted but anyhow some serious
brain camp brain cramp situation going
on with capturing on b2 this is a
position that I have excellent control
in in the evaluation let me just put it
on right around this point is maybe a
bit misleading because this is it's only
saying negative 0.4 but this is one that
you can see growing just as you start
playing out a bit more in this position
I have good control these dark squares
if we just key in on the main difference
between these bishops he's without
question relevant my dark square bishop
whereas the light square bishop really
doesn't have a say or isn't really felt
in this position at all I have good
control over these pawn advances I have
good dark square control over here I'll
be playing g6 again there light square
Bishop isn't felt in this position mine
certainly is there is some coordinated
effort against b2
so I shouldn't be capturing here what I
should be doing is something like g6 the
computer is pointing out now 85 let me
let me put the arrows on it's pointing
out a5 yeah just advancing although this
would certainly be a candidate as well
just getting into flight square although
as we're seeing there's an additional
reason to be playing a 5 kills Queen a5
idea so a5 first and then some nice
strength and you move with g6 yes g6
root 2 G 3 but I still have this idea
now now I have to do something about
this threat
there's beef or maybe you could even
prep it first with rook to b8 you know
once again with b4 right away takes
we're just taking and these dark squares
are collapsing material is not as big a
factor in these opposite color Bishop
positions it's really who can better
activate their Bishop and its team black
who's able to do that here I'd like to
just what is a clean approach for white
just winning this I think how they did
it is fine
getting their queen active it was just a
time thing yeah they could capture here
and that's what I suspected because of
this rook g3 idea and yeah I'm going to
be losing my queen
I think he's certainly running for the
hills yep there goes my queen
so this was the right idea my opponent
played it well just lost on time and
that was the only thing I had to try for
towards the end if they Bank some more
time in that ending I was just going to
throw in the towel but yeah they had the
right idea everything that they did was
fine with uh you know once they had that
bishop advantage h4 if I'm not playing
h5 myself then this starts to become an
issue some mate threat on g7 so they
played they played it well it just lost
on time at the end yeah no issues with
how they played it here
um what more to say
let me just skim this early part see if
there's well there wasn't anything
missed we can see that from the
evaluation or the graph but neo
interesting opening it's a solid it's
been around for quite some time the
filler our defense exchange variation
hmm opposite sides counseling trying to
get at one another's King you know I
think I really did get to share
everything that I wanted to during the
game so tight one for sure I need to
stay clear of a little capture on b2o
right here even right here I could have
captured but it doesn't like that as no
I couldn't have captured excuse me
Bishop takes pawn King takes on a queen
check there's Queen c3 defending the
bishop and blocking the check so I was
wrong to think that this was a move this
would be some more poor calculation on
my part to go in for that but uh
even if if I didn't still see this as a
move right here I think this is
something I would maybe even still shy
away from in a way like I'm giving a
great value to the bishop on e5 coupled
with Queen f6 it's just as mentioned
really good control over the dark
squares and really the whole position
exerts pressure against their King and
has good control over any ensuing pawn
advance on the Kings side so okay well
got away with one there in the end but
yeah as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and as always I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you